الان الان هناك رشقه جديده من
الصواريخ انطلقت في سماء
قطاع غزه هذه الرشاقات توالت ايضا طوال
الساعات الماضيه هناك ايضا اطلاق الان
صواريخ رشقات متفاوته من الصواريخ نشاهدها
في سماء القطاع
تشاهدون معي تشاهدون معي
مختلفه
وارتفاعات نعم نعم هي
رشقات متتاليه رشقات فيها اتجاهات مختلفه
وفيها ارتفاعات مختلفه لهذه الصواريخ الان
بدات القبه الحديديه تطلق هذه
ايضا من الصواريخ المضاده محاوله
لوقف او صد هذه الصواريخ التي انطلقت الان
من قطاع غزه باتجاهات مختلفه لا نعرف
تحديدا
اتجاهات هذه الصواريخ بعضها الى الشمال
وبعضها الى الشرق من قطاع غزه اذا نتابع
في الساعات القليله الماضيه هو تصعيد واضح
تصعيد من قبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بهذه
القارات التي تتوالى اصوات انفجاراتها
تسمعون معي الان هذا الصوت من الانفجارات
العميقه هو صوت للقبه صواريخ القبه
الحديديه التي تحاول اعتراض هذه الصواريخ
ولكن ايضا اصوات الانفجارات التي
توالت في مناطق مختلفه من قطاع غزه كانت
ناجمه عن الغارات الاسرائيليه اليوم كانت
الغارات مكثفه بين غارات من الطائرات
وايضا غارات من المدفعيه غارات الطائرات
ايضا كانت متتاليه ومتنوعه منها غارات من
صواريخ لطائرات مسيره كانت تستهدف منازل
عديده ويليها ايضا قصف من الطائرات
الحربيه
خلال اقل من 20 دقيقه يعني هناك ثلاث
دفعات شاهدناها على الهواء مباشره انطلقت
من غزه ان كنت غير مخطئه ثلاث دفعات من
غزه باتجاه مناطق مختلفه